today is a very big day in the bitcoin
industry since 2013 when cameron and
tyler winklevoss tried to file for a
bitcoin etf application it was rejected
there have been many many people trying
to get a bitcoin etf approved here in
the united states now there have been
other bitcoin etfs and various etp
structures that have been approved
around the world and have traded and
been very successful but in the united
states regulators have kept a bitcoin
etf out of the market until today today
we get a bitcoin futures etf pro shares
is the first company to actually get one
trading and so when we go ahead and we
look at that the ceo of pro shares he
emphasized that the etf being launched
is a major milestone for the industry he
specifically said that in 1993 remember
for the first equity etf 2002 the first
bond etf and in 2004 was the first gold
etf but 2021 will be the first
cryptocurrency linked etf or the first
bitcoin etf pretty damn cool so how's it
going here you can see eric from
bloomberg was on the show yesterday 280
million dollars worth of the shares was
traded in the first 20 minutes
already in the first 20 minutes it would
be one of the top 15
biggest launch days for an etf in
history absolutely bananas type demand
for this asset and so the big question
is will the bitcoin etf hit a billion
dollars in trading volume for the shares
before the end of the day well james who
also was on the show yesterday said wait
a second 280 in 20 minutes what about
320 million in the first 30 minutes
absolutely bonkers type demand for this
asset the reason is that there are a ton
of investors and also traders who are
sitting on the sideline they want to get
exposure to the asset they previously
haven't been able to for various reasons
now all of a sudden we increase the
access via a futures-based etf and they
are going to come in and participate now
this is not a spot etf it does not
necessarily mean as money goes in
somebody is going then in buying bitcoin
in the spot market they are using
futures to go ahead and get this
exposure but to see this type of demand
for a product that most people believe
retail investors and institutions think
is inferior to a bitcoin spot etf is
pretty compelling if a bitcoin spot etf
was to have been launched today my guess
is that we wouldn't have seen 320
million dollars of trading volume in 30
minutes it would have been something
much much higher but still it is very
impressive to be seeing these numbers
this quickly now the pro shares bitcoin
futures etf is not the only one that is
going to be in the market today they
stand on a pedestal they stand alone
they are the only futures etf for
bitcoin in the united states market but
we know that there are others on the way
valkyrie is launching a bitcoin futures
etf as well it could start trading as
early as tomorrow or maybe on wednesday
but or i'm sorry on thursday but what we
know is that they're not playing around
yesterday they edited their application
they went from btf which was going to be
their bitcoin futures etf ticker symbol
to btfd
now why would they do that well
because in the internet community of
financial assets what you're talking
about in the stock market with the meme
stocks or in the bitcoin in
cryptocurrency world btfd stands for buy
the [ __ ] dip
and if you want to appeal to young
people if you want to appeal to the
community that you're trying to serve
there is no better marketing than to
simply make the ticker btfd
now they edited this to btfd and it
looks like they're going to be able to
actually ship it the valkyrie bitcoin
futures etf symbol will be btfd
now if we continue to look at this you
can see that the internet has already
said wow we like this we've got a meme
taking the old school
drake structure and saying you know what
there's futures etfs named btf nah but
futures etfs named btfd
yes and so this is exactly what the
legacy financial world is starting to
understand is if you can understand the
communities if you can understand these
types of assets who the holders are you
gain an advantage by actually playing to
what they like just as we saw amc say
that they were going to do certain
things that their community really
wanted and just like when the amc ceo
was doing a live stream uh interview and
his computer fell and we saw that he was
sitting doing the interview in his
underwear and the internet went nuts
this is the same type of stuff you're
parlaying right into the hands of the
community which is ultimately what you
want because when you plug into that
network they'll do the work for you and
so already there are people who are
marketing the btfd ticker symbol and
they've got nothing to do with the
company they've got no ownership of it
literally no one can buy it yet but
still the bitcoiners are at work now
it's important to remember that these
are both futures bitcoin
etfs they are not spot
and so there are some challenges with it
it remains to be seen how closely will
they track the price it remains to be
seen what is the actual fee drag going
to be for rolling over the futures on a
monthly basis there's lots of questions
but it doesn't matter still 320 million
dollars of trading volume within the
first 30 minutes is highly impressive
but they're not the only etfs in the
game if we're going to have bitcoin
futures etf immediately people jump and
say well we're probably going to get
bitcoin spot etfs at some point too
and so barry silbert and michael
shunnenstein with grayscale they came
over the top and today they announced
that it is official they have filed the
necessary paperwork to convert the
world's largest bitcoin fund gbtc to
become the first american bitcoin spot
etf you got barry right here saying
grayscale and the new york stock
exchange formally kicked off the process
this morning to convert gbtc into the
first spot based bitcoin etf based in
the united states upon conversion they
will trade under the ticker symbol btc
now of course there are people that are
upset in the bitcoin community saying
using ticker symbol btc is confusing
because it confuses people that are
using btc on the internet not
necessarily to signal the stock but to
actually signal the asset itself again i
don't know what the right answer here is
but of course someone at some point was
going to lay claim to the btc ticker on
the publicly traded markets and so the
largest bitcoin fund in the world doing
it seems natural or seems obvious to me
but i also saw this tweet from michael
schunenstein the ceo of grayscale the
largest asset manager that is specific
to bitcoin and cryptocurrencies where he
said when i joined grayscale in 2014 we
sponsored one investment product the
grayscale bitcoin trust and we managed
about 60 million dollars in aum
today we have 15 products and we manage
more than 53 billion dollars in aun
absolutely nuts to see this type of
growth from an organization that was
started in 2013-2014
so we are likely only going to see this
continue whether it is the bitcoin
futures etfs where people are bringing
future based products into the
investment realm of asset managers and
asset allocators in the traditional
institutional world or whether it is
eventually that spot etf that will get
approved the conversion of gbdtc
and also many others who have made the
application
more and more investors of all types
individuals institutions financial
organizations and nation states are
going to continue to get access to these
assets but when you look at something
like bitcoin that has a fixed supply
there is likely to continue to be the
protection of purchasing power for years
and years to come because still there is
not that much adoption of these assets
there's only about 850 000 bitcoin
addresses that have one bitcoin or more
in them now again there are obviously
highly highly concentrated addresses as
well people who own way more than one
bitcoin but what we are likely to see is
that as more people come into the market
and as bitcoiners continue to solidify
in their minds that this is the greatest
store of value on earth whether you're
talking to a michael saylor or mark
cuban or somebody else they are going to
become more and more unwilling to sell
their bitcoin and so when you look at
this from a market structure standpoint
the etfs both futures based and spot
based along with things like interactive
brokers allowing for ras now to come
into the market there's a wall of demand
that is coming and bitcoiners are just
unwilling to sell the asset that they
believe is their reserve currency that
to me feels like the biggest story here
is that these etfs etc are going to
bring so much demand but it's not going
to matter people just aren't willing to
sell their bitcoin right now